[Musique]
joyeuses Pâques les enfants j'espère que
vous avez eu un beau dimanche et que les
cloches sont passées chez vous moi je te
regroupe elles m'ont apporté en une
énorme en chocolat montre le nous
nounours il ne reste plus que le ruban
je l'ai mangé
[Musique]
je descends à tout de suite patron
bonsoir tout le monde mais ne veux ont
été sage des petits singes et on a
beaucoup joué je le sais hier soir
[Musique]
les cloches nous avaient quitté elle ne
sonnait plus
là-bas elles ont dit sa nuit
alors elle s'en revenus
[Musique]
à toute volé des dons
en vous reposer une belle cloche de
[Musique]
nuit
cloches j'aimerais autant qu'il
s'approche parking
[Musique]
quelle belle journée nounours
j'ai sommeil voilà ce que c'est de faire
les petits fous le soir
on dormira tout de suite
n'est-ce pas
[Musique]
tu laisseras la fenêtre ouverte ce soir
pour qu'on voit le soleil demain matin
quand on se réveille et on lui dira
bonjour soleil d'accord les enfants
dormir vite
[Musique]
bonne nuit
alors nounours tu es content quelle
belle journée patron alors je souhaite
que tous les enfants soient aussi
heureux que Nicolas Pimprenelle était
trois neveux mon cher nounours en route
bonne nuit les enfants
embrassez bien fort vos parents
n'oubliez pas de faire votre toilette de
bien vous laver le donf
c'est tout patron oui et faites de beaux
rêves
à demain
[Musique]